welcome to this video playing Grand
Master dr. John none here with black
yeah what do I play maybe maybe you
should draw the fiddy doors something
else and this probably I is playing a
sophisticated line against that not
something boring like d takes ok let's
stake out some space on the queenside so
um possible long castling is not so easy
from now it seems that he is going for
that anyway hmm interesting hmm
yeah i'm not a huge expert on this
opening g5 maybe can i do that that
looks interesting try to unsettle them
in the center I mean details night eggs
should be quite nice threatening Knight
f3 so it's a bit uncomfortable for him
and if he takes d5 95 looks really good
I'm not threatening de for in some way
hmm interesting ok so let's take what
now queen bee six maybe a unpinning and
they have some funky ideas here let's
say if he takes f6 Knight f6 de 5 Bishop
c5 he takes Knight Bishop f2 checking
due to Queen III checkmate always good
to have some some silly tricks up your
sleeve ok he just played Queen d2 hmm
going for development take the form
may is preparing to Castle long my
development is not great maybe I can
still take him I mean I'm threatening to
take on f3 so it probably has to react
him I mean whatever what I'm trying to
say with has to react us that he cannot
just cancel or something so taking first
and what now my idea was that I have
naija form in some situations
a broad Queen to a five-year trying to
prevent castles maybe come on have to
play with him falling behind on time
quite a bit
he does not have to Castle castle long
necessarily should age 6 I don't know
let's be quick him a mattress Castle
short
hmm not easy in fact I cannot so easily
develop here I am canceling short was
expected by now
and night f5 as an ism isn't isn't a big
problem him i wonder if i can take on d4
it looks look suicidal almost I state i
don't i don't really see a move here
don't really see a move any bishop move
last night at five jan I don't know
maybe this this Bishop a6 wasn't the
greatest idea ever ok I'm taking this
and hope for the best yeah he's sitting
in d3 check iam so it's not it's not
totally simple I think to wipe me out
Knight takes I've got Bishop c5 I guess
maybe a very shaky position King h1 I go
naija form I guess just attacking h2
with the raw I have long castles in this
position that's really important okay so
Bishop c5 that seems like a good move
Wow for the position ok I have to have
to be this this i thought was okay rook
takes rook deform or not I know rook t4
takes Bishop takes he has Bishop e3 ah
ah time morning yes Bishop e3 I shoot
that's not good
nice got Bishop you three dummy yeah
stupid stupid stupid yeah probably was
bad anyway but still should have seen
that
you know I was thinking Queen III Knight
g4 yeah but he has rupee a check this
will kill me probably let's just I mean
I have no no no choice here anyway so
let's just play the move okay if he goes
Queen f5 check i can play route 27
counter check maybe rookie 800k it down
will probably kill me no it's doing that
mmm I can't shake him on g1 right jack
isn't this kind of winning how lucky was
that Wow then sometimes you just check
you just damn lucky check me whatever
what a rotten game guy completely
crushed me and then blunder to that yeah
I wanted to resign but I just wanted to
play with a couple of more moves yeah
that very complicated position very
complicated I mean I think this this
looks kind of okay at g5g five and and I
had a feeling that this should be quite
nice but i also have a very clear
digital kind of thing here like I had
this before it's really it's possible
that i had this before the the engine is
giving c5 here that's an interesting
move oh and a pretty good one I'm
threatening on deform so white has to
take this is this is really nice
so probably here and now yeah this is a
very nice position now can do this and
it just just play normal stuff it looks
a lot like a Sicilian actually hear some
kind of Niger avoir sharp sicilian i
know there's no pollen 86 but it looks
looks like it a bit yeah okay I went
here and just played this move which is
slow but I wanted to prepare long
castling yeah the computer has actually
still think computer still giving my
position as kind of okay but with very
wild lines not with this one but with e
5 yeah when this is a move that I had
had expected all I mean thought was
possible but I didn't really see how I'm
losing directly so I went for at him
rook f6 is the engines line that looks
very scary that's really scary this is
what got the computer gives and don't
ask me about this position this is like
51 pawn down 113 d3 crazy yeah this this
actually the engine likes my position 94
Bishop c5 it preferred long castles and
now naija force is ok for black
apparently he yeah this makes some sense
just trying to occupy e5 i was i was
totally not seeing that here yeah that
this was I absolutely did not did not
see Bishop e3 before but I didn't really
see something else it's quite funny the
computer is completely unimpressed here
and wants to play this and then gives
gifts black and ok position
huh wine check check check counter check
Jan dad is it is kind of tricky he
cannot go to everyone I mean he has no
square he has to play rook c5 of all
moves this is made checkmate Roxy 5 and
now the comp gives Bishop d3 Wow check
all rights totally crazy and now this
and the evaluation is equal equal ok
whatever so and this is not sound
working at all look p 8 yeah and Queen
III is winning this is also winning but
it seems to be tricky yeah okay this is
this fella to this is made but he can do
this check this and the problem is Roxy
five that's such a strange mood and it's
the only move here if you if you this is
drawn I'm checking him and this is easy
too sorry this is easy to overlook that
you should have this move in fact and
now Bishop d3 he has bishop efore as a
defense and that's totally inhuman
impossible really impossible yeah i was
very lucky i was down down the position
and one minute and he fell into that
trap into this into this mate yeah okay
there was a up here in any case i am an
entertaining game thanks for watching